From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台，欢迎收听《美国生活》。
Hi, Dad, how are you doing? I'm doing fine.
嗨，爸爸，你最近好吗？我还不错。
When Aric was a kid, his dad would leave for six months at a time. He was in the Merchant Marines. He'd be in Guam or Scotland or God knows where, and Aric would record these cassettes and send them off to him.
当Aric还是个孩子时，他的父亲经常一走就是半年。他是一名商船海员。他有时在关岛，有时在苏格兰，或者是天知道什么地方。Aric会录下这些磁带寄给他。
Have you been in the desert? Did the Easter Bunny send you an Easter basket? If he did, you better make sure there's no lizards in it. Dad, when are you going to be coming back up to stay? I'm anxious to see you or at least hear your voice. Yeah, send me a tape, Dad.
你去过沙漠吗？复活节兔子给你送复活节篮子了吗？如果送了，你最好检查一下里面有没有蜥蜴。爸爸，你什么时候能回来长住？我很想见你，或者至少想听听你的声音。是的，寄回一盘磁带给我吧，爸爸。
His request that his father record a tape for him is repeated over and over again on these tapes. Here's Aric, probably four years later, on another tape, in seventh grade. His hope that his dad would respond was so great that every cassette that he sent, he would only record on one side. The other side was blank for his dad to fill in and send back. Never did, though.
他在这些磁带里一遍又一遍地请求父亲也录一盘给他。这是四年后的Aric，在另一盘磁带里，那时他上七年级。他渴望父亲回应的愿望如此强烈，以至于他寄出的每一盘磁带都只录了一面。另一面留白，好让父亲录好后寄回来。但他从来没这么做过。
You can use this tape to send me-- I want a tape back, bubba. And I really hope you can get your hands on a tape recorder. Well, I guess you did, or else you wouldn't be listening to it right now, but-- I just got my hair cut yesterday. I don't know if you'd like it or not. It's--
你可以用这盘带子给我回录——我想要回一盘带子，老爸。我真的希望你能搞到一个录音机。嗯，我想你肯定搞到了，不然你现在也不会在听这个了，但是——我昨天剪了头发。不知道你会不会喜欢。它——
These recordings are filled with so much yearning that, even when Aric tells his dad about his haircut, you can hear it. Aric reads his dad a poem he's written about the environment. He talks about the weather, two feet of snow. He plays his clarinet, though even this gets a nervous preamble.
这些录音充满了如此多的渴望，甚至当Aric向父亲讲述他的发型时，你都能听出来。Aric给父亲读了他写的一首关于环境的诗。他聊起天气，谈到两英尺厚的积雪。他吹奏了他的单簧管，尽管这之前还有一段紧张的开场白。
I don't know. I'll play my piece for you that I'm going to play tomorrow. But my reed is-- it's a new reed and it's not fully soaked yet. So there'll be squeaking. It'll be OK tomorrow because it's soaking right now. So I'll be squeaking. OK, I'm going to play it now.
我不知道。我要为你演奏明天要表演的曲子。但我的簧片——这是一个新的簧片，还没完全浸泡好。所以会有吱吱声。明天应该没问题，因为它现在正在浸泡。所以会有吱吱声。好吧，我要开始吹了。
[PLAYING CLARINET]
[吹奏单簧管]
I know this is the saddest tape in the world that we're starting the show with this week, and I'm just doing it so I can talk about this choice. As adults, we have this funny choice. Are we going to sit down with our parents and talk about the stuff that hurt us and didn't make sense to us when we were kids? And it's hard to know if it's worth it sometimes, if it's just going to make your parents feel bad. And what are they going to say, anyway? But Aric's never understood why his father, in all those years, never sent him a tape back. Not once.
我知道本周节目开头放这盘磁带显得太悲伤了，我这么做只是为了谈谈这种选择。作为成年人，我们面临一个有趣的抉择。我们要不要坐下来和父母谈谈那些曾经伤害过我们、在童年时让我们感到困惑的事情？有时很难知道这是否值得，如果这只会让父母感到难过。反正他们又能说什么呢？但Aric一直不明白，为什么他父亲那些年从来没回过他一盘磁带。一次都没有。
So, not long ago, he got together with his father.
所以不久前，他去见了他的父亲。
Those tapes ripped the guts right out of me. They're from an era of my life that was so sad.
那些磁带真是让我肝肠寸断。它们来自我生命中一段如此悲伤的时期。
This is Aric's dad. Back when those tapes were sent, during the months when he wasn't away at sea, he was often just living out of his car, scraping by. He and Aric's mom split up pretty early. And I've got to say, this little encounter did not start so well. Aric played his father a bit at the old tape, and his dad cried and said it was killing him. It was just too sad, too hard to listen to, knowing all the ways he'd let Aric down back then.
这是Aric的父亲。在那些磁带寄出的日子里，当他不在海上时，他往往只能住在车里，勉强糊口。他和Aric的母亲很早就分开了。不得不说，这次小小的重逢开始得并不顺利。Aric给父亲放了一点当年的旧录音，他父亲哭了，说这简直要了他的命。那太悲伤了，太难听下去了，因为他知道自己当年在那么多方面辜负了Aric。
And then, finally, Aric asked him the question that he brought him there to ask him-- why he never sent a tape back. And his dad was as honest as he could be.
然后，Aric终于问出了他此行要问的问题——为什么他从不回寄磁带。他的父亲尽可能地坦诚回答。
I don't know. I can't answer that. I was a failure, a total failure in that. I guess I figured I'd get home and talk to you. I should have had the strength to do it. I didn't have the strength to do it. That's my only answer. I didn't have the strength to do that.
我不知道。我无法回答。在那方面我是个失败者，彻底的失败者。我想我当时觉得等我回家后会跟你说的。我本该有勇气去做的。但我没有。这就是我唯一的回答。我没有勇气那么做。
And why didn't you?
那你为什么没有？
I don't know.
我不知道。
I believe you.
我相信你。
It's my only answer. Sorry. You know that? You know how sorry I am about that?
这是我唯一的回答。对不起。你知道吗？你知道我有多抱歉吗？
Yeah.
知道。
That ain't worth much, I guess, but--
我想这没什么价值，但是——
No, it is.
不，很有价值。
It's all I can do.
这是我唯一能做的了。
Was that satisfying?
这让你感到满足吗？
No. No, I don't know. No, it wasn't satisfying. But yes, I think I did believe him.
不。不，我不知道。不，那并不满足。但是的，我想我确实相信他。
I talked to Aric about all this on the phone.
我在电话里和Aric聊了这一切。
I have two completely different understandings of my dad in my head. One is that dad I knew and missed and was really mad at as a kid, and one is the dad I know now. And I don't know. I feel like maybe asking him those questions, I wanted to conjure up that younger version and see what a total jerk he was so that I could really be mad at him. It didn't happen. And I just saw the dad that I've known for the past few years. And I'm not really mad at him.
我的脑海里有两个截然不同的父亲形象。一个是小时候我认识、想念且非常怨恨的那个爸爸，另一个是我现在认识的爸爸。我不知道。我觉得也许问他那些问题，我是想唤起那个年轻版本的他，看看他曾经是多么混蛋，好让我能彻底恨他。但这没有发生。我看到的只是我过去几年认识的那个爸爸。我对他并没有那么怨恨了。
Right. You're still mad at that young dad.
对。你还在怨恨那个年轻时的爸爸。
But he's gone. And there's this sweet, kind of sad, loving, older guy there now.
但他已经不在了。现在这里是一个温和、有点悲伤、充满爱意的老头。
But how unsatisfying for you and for everyone who wants to confront their parents, given the fact that the people who they're mad at are sort of gone and have been replaced by these kinder, gentler, more sensitive people.
但对于你和所有想要与父母对质的人来说，这太令人不满足了，因为你怨恨的那个人其实已经不在了，被这些更友善、更温柔、更敏感的人取代了。
Totally unsatisfying. And I think probably then confronting your parents never works. Confronting your parents never works because by the time you get around to doing it, your parents are totally different people.
完全不满足。而且我想可能与父母对质永远没用。对质永远没用，因为当你终于去做这件事时，你的父母已经是完全不同的人了。
Yeah.
是的。
They're gone, and there are these different beings sitting in front of you when you confront them.
他们已经变了，当你与他们对质时，坐在你面前的是完全不同的生命。
The problem, of course, is that we still have our questions about the past, whether or not those people we've got beef with are still around to answer the questions. Today on our radio show, we have stories of two people who head off bravely for answers, despite these odds. Act One is about a man who's handed a mystery that he could really use his father's help in unraveling. But unfortunately, his father is dead.
当然，问题在于我们对过去仍然有疑问，不管我们要追究的人是否还在。今天在我们的电台节目里，我们有两个故事，讲述了两个尽管困难重重，却依然勇敢前往寻找答案的人。第一幕关于一个男人得到一个谜团，他非常希望能得到父亲的帮助来解开。但遗憾的是，他的父亲已经去世了。
In Act Two, we have a son, a father, and questions so unusual that their answers may require an army of Russian lumberjacks, a giant circular trench in the Sahara Desert, and possibly-- just possibly-- a website. Stay with us.
在第二幕中，我们有一对父子和一些不同寻常的问题，其答案可能需要一支俄罗斯伐木工军队、撒哈拉沙漠中一个巨大的圆形沟渠，可能还有——仅仅是有可能——一个网站。请继续收听。
Act One, Make Him Say Uncle. This is the story of a family. And every family has a black sheep. In Lenny's family growing up, it was Uncle Abie.
第一幕，让他说出真相。这是一个家庭的故事。每个家庭都有害群之马。在Lenny成长过程中，那是他的Abie叔叔。
Uncle Abie was the person in my family that I was always told, don't be like Abie. Don't be like Abie. You know, there was like-- he was like a model of what not to be. My father would always say to me, don't read in bed at night. Uncle Abie reads in bed. And what was bad about that was that you need a book as a crutch to go to sleep at night.
Abie叔叔是我家里那个总被叮嘱“别像Abie那样”的人。别像Abie那样。你知道，他就像是个反面教材。我父亲总是对我说，晚上别在床上看书。Abie叔叔就在床上看书。糟糕的是，你需要一本书作为拐杖才能在晚上入睡。
Or Uncle Abie read on the toilet. Now, don't read on the toilet. That's bad. It's not clean.
或者Abie叔叔在厕所看书。听着，别在厕所看书。那很糟糕。不卫生。
Uncle Abie was always an hour late for everything. Uncle Abie went out with a string of women when he was single, in a way that seemed unsavory to Lenny's parents. Uncle Abie couldn't be trusted. There are all kinds of things about Uncle Abie to avoid. So Uncle Abie didn't come around much, even though he lived right in the neighborhood.
Abie叔叔做什么都迟到一个小时。他单身时交过一连串的女朋友，以至于Lenny的父母觉得他很不正经。Abie叔叔不可信。总之要避开关于Abie叔叔的一切。所以Abie叔叔很少露面，尽管他就住在附近。
This was in the Bronx in the 1950s. Lenny's dad operated a sewing machine at a factory in the garment district. His mom did alterations in a department store. There wasn't much money. Lenny and his older brother and his parents lived in a one-bedroom apartment.
那是20世纪50年代的布朗克斯。Lenny的父亲在服装区的一家工厂操作缝纫机。他母亲在百货公司做改衣工作。家里没什么钱。Lenny和他哥哥以及父母住在一间一居室的公寓里。
So fast forward several decades. Lenny grows up, moves out. And by the time he's 31, his mom had passed away. His father was in the hospital with cancer. And Lenny's visiting his dad there.
时间快进几十年。Lenny长大搬了出去。他31岁时，母亲去世了。他父亲因癌症住进了医院。Lenny去医院看望父亲。
And Abie comes in and he pulls me aside and he says, I have a secret to tell you, but I can't tell you until your father dies. So I just was like, OK, leave me alone, you know? And I just didn't-- I said, fine.
Abie走过来把我拉到一边说，我有个秘密要告诉你，但在你父亲去世前我不能说。所以我当时只是说，好吧，别管我，你知道吗？我只是说，行吧。
So then my father did die. And it was about a week after my father died, just a little bit after the funeral. And Abie called up, and we were talking about some pieces of furniture that he-- actually, he had gone to my father's apartment and taken furniture without asking us.
后来我父亲确实去世了。就在葬礼后大约一周，Abie打来电话，我们正聊起一些家具，其实他已经去过我父亲的公寓，没经我们同意就拿走了家具。
Wow.
哇。
And we're talking about the furniture. And then I said to him, so what's the secret? And there's this long pause, and then he says, no, no, forget it. No, never mind. And I go, come on. You said there was a secret. I mean, you said this. What is it? And he said, I really don't want to talk about it.
我们正说着家具的事。然后我问他，到底是什么秘密？电话那头长久的沉默，然后他说，不，不，算了。不，没什么。我说，得了吧。你说有个秘密。我的意思是，你提到了这个。到底是什么？他说，我真的不想谈这个。
I kind of nudged him and finally he said, OK, I'll tell you the secret. And I said, what is it? And he said, I'm your father. And there was just this-- this was just completely out of the blue. There was no clues in my upbringing. There was nothing. And my father had just died, and I'm in the process of mourning him and thinking about my connection to him. So I said, what do you mean?
我软磨硬泡，他终于说，好吧，我告诉你秘密。我问是什么。他说，我是你的父亲。那一刻简直是……这完全是突如其来的。我的成长过程中没有任何线索。什么都没有。我父亲刚去世，我正处于哀悼中，思考着我和他的血缘联系。所以我问，你这是什么意思？
And he said, well, your parents tried to have you for a long time-- and there's 10 years between me and my brother. Then your father came to me at my workshop, and he had a jar. And he came over and he gave it to me and explained that he needed some semen. So he said he went in the bathroom and he produced the semen and came back. And then he said, nine months later, you were born.
他说，嗯，你的父母努力了很久才生下你——我和我哥哥之间差了10岁。然后你父亲来到我的工作室，带着一个罐子。他走过来把罐子给我，解释说他需要一些精子。他说他进了厕所，提取了精子又回来了。然后他说，九个月后，你出生了。
Again, it just seemed completely preposterous-- I mean the whole idea. Then Abie, kind of sensing that I was probably fairly freaked out, said, don't worry, though, because your father told me that they mixed the sperm together.
同样，这一切看起来完全荒谬——我的意思是整个主意。然后Abie察觉到我可能被吓坏了，说，别担心，因为你父亲告诉我他们把精子混合在一起了。
They mixed the two brothers? His sperm and your dad's sperm?
他们混合了两个兄弟的精子？他和你的父亲？
Right. So there's a chance-- there's some statistical chance, I guess. And the other thing that he said on the phone was he said, you know, you're a smart fella. And I've watched you at school and all of your accomplishments and I've always thought it's because of me.
对。所以有个机会——我想大概有某种统计学上的可能性。他在电话里还说，你知道，你是个聪明的家伙。我在学校看过你的表现和你所有的成就，我一直认为这是因为我。
And is that like the most horrible thing you can imagine, when he says that? Is that very much like a Darth Vader--
这是你能想象到的最可怕的事情吗，当他这么说的时候？这很像达斯·维达那样——
Absolutely. I was in a complete, total state of shock. And I just thought, wow, whose movie am I in? The whole thing was completely bizarre.
绝对是。我完全陷入了震惊状态。我只是想，哇，我这是在谁的电影里？整件事完全离谱。
Did it seem believable to you at all?
这听起来可信吗？
It felt like someone had spun me around like 100 times and I was just standing there, reeling and trying to put the details together. And it seemed kind of crazy. And especially the details, like when he told me it was about artificial insemination. I thought, that's got to be really early for artificial insemination.
感觉就像有人把我转了100圈，我正站在那儿，踉踉跄跄地试图拼凑细节。这看起来有点疯狂。特别是细节，比如他说是人工授精。我想，那对于人工授精来说太早了吧。
So I went up to the medical library at Columbia and I just started looking it up. And sure enough, I found these documents that said that in the early-- actually, I probably would be one of the early artificial insemination babies in the United States. But in the early days, they asked for a family member, which of course they never do now, and they also did mix the sperm. I found that detail. And that was the detail that seemed to me the craziest.
所以我去了哥伦比亚大学的医学图书馆开始查找。果然，我找到了一些文件，上面说在早期的——其实，我可能是美国最早的人工授精婴儿之一。但在早期，他们确实要求亲属提供，当然现在没人这么做了，而且他们也确实会混合精子。我找到了那个细节。那个细节在我看来是最疯狂的。
The mixing the sperm?
混合精子？
Yeah. And they don't do it anymore because obviously it doesn't do anything, other than make the person who wants to be-- who has been trying to be the father feel better.
是啊。现在他们不再这么做了，因为显然除了让那个想当父亲的人感觉好一点外，并没有什么实际用处。
It's such a beautiful idea, though. It's like a firing squad, but in reverse.
但这个想法真美。就像行刑队，反过来的版本。
That is absolutely true.
那绝对是真的。
Like in a firing squad, each person would choose to believe they weren't the one who hit the prisoner. And in this, everybody would choose to believe they were the one.
就像在行刑队里，每个人都会选择相信不是自己打中了囚犯。在这里，每个人都会选择相信自己才是那个父亲。
Right.
对。
So I did that research. And then the other thing that was interesting was that my father was this amazing cheapskate, and he never had a checkbook because he wanted to deal straight in cash. So he had kept these meticulous notebooks of everything he spent, and particularly medical things. And I found this notebook with all of his expenses going back to the year I was born.
所以我做了研究。另一件有趣的事是，我父亲是个了不起的铁公鸡，他从不用支票簿，因为他想直接用现金交易。所以他一直保留着详尽的笔记本，记录了所有开支，特别是医疗方面的。我找到了这本笔记本，记录着从我出生那年开始的所有支出。
Going back to the year you were born, but not before?
追溯到你出生那年，但没有之前的？
Not before, yeah.
没有之前的，对。
Oh. So was it helpful?
哦。那有帮助吗？
Well, yeah, because it listed the name of the gynecologist. So I figured, OK, I'm going to track him down. So I called up. He was dead. But his wife answered the phone and she said that his records all went to some other guy. So I tried to find that guy. Called him for two weeks, I remember, and his line was constantly busy. And then when I reached him, it turned out he had just died, like, that week.
嗯，有，因为它列出了妇科医生的名字。所以我心想，好，我要找到他。但我打过去时，他已经去世了。他妻子接了电话，说他的病历都转给另一个人了。所以我试着找到那个人。我记得我给他打了两周电话，他的线路一直忙。等我终于打通时，他竟然就在那周去世了。
Part of that time, what I was wondering about was-- I went back and thought, is there any clues? If this was true, why were there no clues? And the only clue I could up with-- the only clues I could come up with was this idea that I just never felt part of that family.
有一段时间，我在想——我回过头去想，有什么线索吗？如果这是真的，为什么一点迹象都没有？我能想到的唯一线索——我能想到的唯一迹象就是我一直觉得我不属于那个家庭。
Though everybody has that feeling at one point or another when they're a kid.
虽然每个人小时候都有过这种感觉。
Right, absolutely. Only everybody doesn't have the opportunity to find out that the feeling is true. My brother, by his own admission, he said, we never felt like you were one of us.
对，绝对是。但不是每个人都有机会发现这种感觉是真的。我哥哥自己也承认，他说，我们从来没觉得你是我们的一员。
[LAUGHING]
[笑声]
"You're really different from us," is the way he put it.
“你和我们真的很不一样，”他是这么说的。
And what were the differences?
有什么区别呢？
My father and my brother very much are very controlled people. Everything had to be in its place. Everything was orderly. And I was like this little spark. I was going around trying to have a good time. I was very-- the way they described me as a kid is overly sensitive.
我父亲和我哥哥是非常克制的人。一切都必须井井有条。一切都很规整。而我就像个小火花。我总是到处跑，想玩得开心。我非常——他们小时候形容我是一个过于敏感的人。
And you mean overly sensitive like, literally, you were just an emotional kid, like a normal emotional kid?
你是说过于敏感，字面意义上的，就是说你只是个情绪化的孩子，像正常的孩子一样？
Yeah, like I cried a lot. I now, after having children, realized I wasn't particularly oversensitive. I was just normal. I lived in a kind of imaginative, fantasy world that, to them, I seemed like I was different.
是啊，我哭得很多。现在我自己有了孩子，意识到我并没有特别敏感。我只是正常的。我生活在一个充满想象力的幻想世界里，在他们看来，我显得很不一样。
And because he seemed different, Lenny got a lot of-- not punishments, exactly. It was more like a steady stream of never-ending reminders to simmer down, settle down, be a nice boy, be more like them. And of course, in there somewhere, don't be like Uncle Abie. Any burst of enthusiasm, any odd thoughts expressed out loud, any impulsive deed or comment could be cut short by his parents, sometimes gently, sometimes not so gently.
因为他显得很不一样，Lenny得到了很多——算不上惩罚，更像是源源不断的提醒：安静点，别闹了，做个乖孩子，像他们一样。当然，其中还夹杂着“别像Abie叔叔一样”。任何热情爆发、大声表达的古怪想法、冲动的行为或评论，都会被父母打断，有时委婉，有时粗暴。
So 1985, my Uncle Abie died. It was four years after my dad died. And I went to the funeral with my wife. And nobody was there. My Uncle Abie was the kind of guy that, I don't know, everyone hated him? He was obnoxious. There was literally no one there. I've never been to a funeral with nobody there. It was somewhere way out in Long Island.
1985年，Abie叔叔去世了。那是我父亲去世四年后。我和妻子去了葬礼。一个人都没有。Abie叔叔是那种，我不知道，每个人都讨厌他？他很讨厌。现场真的一个人都没有。我从没见过一个人都没有的葬礼。那是在长岛很远的地方。
It was me and my wife, his son and his family, and, like, one neighbor from the old neighborhood in the Bronx. And after the funeral was over, I go and talk to the Les, who is Abie's son, and I said, look, I don't know if you ever heard the story. And I told him the story about this.
只有我和我妻子，他儿子一家，还有那个来自布朗克斯老邻居的一个人。葬礼结束后，我去找Abie的儿子Les谈，我说，听着，我不知道你有没有听说过这个故事。我把那个故事告诉了他。
About the jar and the whole thing?
关于罐子和整件事？
About the jar and the whole thing. And Les says, I'm sure that's not true. And I said, really? Why? He said, well, I've got to tell you. At around that time, my father was delusional. In fact, we had to lock him up. We had to put him away in an institution because he was hearing voices. So he said, I don't think that anything he said would have been too accurate. So he was like, nah, nah. It's probably not true.
关于罐子和整件事。Les说，我相信那不是真的。我说，真的？为什么？他说，我得告诉你，在那段时间里，我父亲患有妄想症。事实上，我们不得不把他锁起来。我们不得不把他关进机构，因为他有幻听。所以他说，我不认为他说的任何话是准确的。他就像是，别听了，那大概不是真的。
So that was the thing that completely put the whole thing to rest in my mind for a long time. At that point, my wife said, look, what difference does it make? You grew up with your father. You thought he was your father. That's really the thing that's important. So you'll never know, and just leave it at that. It seemed like, yeah, that's true. Just get on with your life.
所以那件事在很长一段时间里彻底平息了我的疑惑。在那一点上，我妻子说，看，这有什么区别？你和你父亲一起长大。你一直以为他是你父亲。那才是真正重要的。你永远不会知道真相的，就这样算了吧。这似乎是对的。继续过你的生活吧。
And Lenny does get on with his life. For over 15 years, he pretty much let the question rest right there.
Lenny继续过他的生活。在那之后的15年里，他基本上让这个问题搁置在那里。
Can I ask you a couple of really basic questions before we go into what happens next?
在我们进入下一步之前，我能问你几个非常基本的问题吗？
Sure, absolutely.
当然，没问题。
Who do you look like?
你长得像谁？
Hm. I don't-- I look like my mother.
嗯。我不——我长得像我母亲。
OK.
好的。
Yeah. But I've always felt that I have my father's body type. He was stringy, his stringy muscles. I look like I'm a runner.
是啊。但我一直觉得我有我父亲的体型。他很精瘦，那种精瘦的肌肉。我看起来像个跑步运动员。
And Uncle Abie? What did Uncle Abie's body look like?
Abie叔叔呢？他的身材是什么样的？
He was kind of squarer, solid, chunkier. The other detail about Abie, which wasn't a genetic thing, was that he had this huge cleft in his skull from some childhood accident. I always thought he got hit in the head with an ax or something and he had, like, this dent in his skull. The whole thing about Abie was kind of like repulsion toward him.
他比较方正，结实，粗壮。关于Abie的另一个细节，不是遗传的，是他的头骨上有一个巨大的凹痕，是因为童年的一次意外。我一直以为他被斧头击中头部之类，导致头骨上有个坑。整个关于Abie的感觉就是对他有一种排斥感。
As years passed, for Lenny, this question about his father and Uncle Abie is like a cut that never quite heals right. It's a hard question to have sitting in the back of your mind. What if your parents were lying to you your entire childhood about something so basic? And finally, a couple of years ago, the miracle that is American science conspired with the miracle that is online shopping to make DNA tests ubiquitous enough and cheap enough for anybody. And Lenny decided to see if it would be possible to settle the question of who his father was once and for all with a DNA test.
随着岁月流逝，对于Lenny来说，关于父亲和Abie叔叔的问题就像一个永远无法愈合的伤口。这是一个坐在脑海深处难以解决的问题。如果你的父母在你整个童年时期就某个如此基本的事情对你撒谎，那该怎么办？终于，几年前，美国科学带来的奇迹与在线购物的奇迹结合起来，使得DNA检测变得无处不在且足够便宜。Lenny决定看看能否通过DNA检测一劳永逸地解决谁是他父亲的问题。
So he looked for envelopes that his dad might have licked to get a remnant of DNA. And he found some. Excited by this, he moved to the next step.
于是他找父亲可能舔过的信封来获取DNA残留。他找到了一些。受此激励，他进入了下一步。
So I called my cousin, Lesley, up. And I said to him, look, I'm thinking about trying to do this in a more serious way. How do you feel about it? He was OK about it. At the end of the conversation, which I had basically called to ask him if he could find some letters for me, there was a pause on the phone. And then he says, by the way, I've got to tell you. You remember the last time you asked me about did I know about this? And I said I didn't know. He said, I lied to you. And I said, what? He said, I lied to you. And he said, well, when I was 12 years old, Abie took me aside and told me that same story he told you, way before my father died. And he said, don't ever tell Lenny.
所以我给表弟Lesley打了电话。我说，听着，我正考虑用更严肃的方式去做这个测试。你觉得怎么样？他表示没问题。在谈话结束时，我本意只是问他能不能帮我找些信件，电话里出现了沉默。然后他说，顺便说一下，我得告诉你。你记得上次你问我是不是知道这件事吗？我说我不知道。他说，我撒谎了。我说，什么？他说，我撒谎了。他说，嗯，当我12岁时，Abie把我拉到一边，告诉了我他在我父亲去世前告诉你的那个同样的故事。他说，永远别告诉Lenny。
That's what Abie said to him?
Abie是那么对他说的？
Abie said to him, don't tell Lenny. Swear you'll never tell him. So-- wow. When he said that, then I thought, this has got to be true because here's Abie telling Lesley, like 30, 40 years before my father died, that this story happened, that this thing happened. So that was really a turning point.
Abie对他说，别告诉Lenny。发誓你永远不会告诉他。所以——哇。当他说出那句话时，我心想，这一定是真的，因为这是Abie在父亲去世前三四十年就告诉Lesley这件事的，这件事情真的发生过。所以那真的是一个转折点。
Yeah. Suddenly, it seems like it's probably true.
是的。突然间，看起来它可能是真的。
Exactly. Then I tilt over to thinking like, wow, then it must be true. But I don't know. There's just, I don't know-- there's something fishy about the story. There's something that I don't quite believe or I just find it hard to believe that there isn't-- that I could have grown up and nobody would-- you know how like, in a movie, someone would take you aside and whisper to you, (WHISPERING) hey, there's something you don't know about yourself. There was just nothing of that.
正是。然后我倾向于认为，哇，那它一定是真的。但我不知道。我还是觉得——故事里有些鱼腥味。有些事情我不完全相信，或者我只是觉得难以相信，如果那是真的，我怎么会长大而没有人——你知道像在电影里，有人会把你拉到一边低声说（耳语）嘿，有些关于你自己的事你不知道。什么都没有。
But somebody did do that. They did it in 1981, when your dad died.
但确实有人那么做过。他们是在1981年你父亲去世时做的。
That's true. That's true. But there's something about Abie-- I guess I still feel there's something unreliable about him, that there's something, I don't know, self-interested. In a funny kind of way, for the story to work, for it to point to Abie, it all depends on whether you trust Abie or not. Do I trust Abie? Because if I trust Abie, then what he told me and what he told his son is true. But if I don't trust Abie, if I doubt Abie, then the story's not true.
那是真的。那是真的。但Abie身上有些东西——我想我依然觉得他有些不可靠，有些，我不知道，自私。从一种有趣的角度看，要让这个故事成立，要指向Abie，这完全取决于你是否信任Abie。我信任Abie吗？因为如果我信任他，那么他告诉我和他儿子说的话就是真的。但如果我不信任他，如果我怀疑他，那么这个故事就不是真的。
So it goes back to that whole-- it takes me back to that whole conflict with me and Abie as a child. Abie's not trustworthy. Don't believe him. And the circumstantial evidence that might make you feel, "yeah, the story points that way" isn't enough for me. But I don't know.
所以它又回到了那个——让我回到小时候我和Abie之间的冲突。Abie不可信。别相信他。而那些可能让你觉得“是的，故事指向那边”的间接证据对我来说还不够。但我不知道。
There's a joke. I've got to tell you this joke. So there's this guy, and he thinks his wife is cheating on him, so he hires a detective. And he says to the detective, I've got to tell you that I think my wife is cheating on me, but I just have this element of doubt, and I want to clear it up. So the detective says, OK, I'll follow her and I'll give you a report.
有个笑话。我一定要告诉你这个笑话。有一个人，他怀疑妻子出轨，于是请了个侦探。他对侦探说，我必须告诉你，我觉得妻子出轨了，但我心里有个疑虑，想弄清楚。侦探说，好吧，我会跟踪她并给你汇报。
So he comes back, like, two weeks later and he's got all these photographs. And he says, well, here you see there's a photograph. You're leaving home. Then there's a photograph of this man ringing the doorbell. Then your wife and he go out. And then they go to this hotel, and I was able to photograph them, see them embracing in front of the hotel. Then they go in the hotel, and I telephoto lens up to the room. They go in the room. They take off all their clothes. And then they close the shades. And the guy goes, see? That's what I mean-- that element of doubt.
两周后他回来了，带着一堆照片。他说，你看，这有一张照片。你离开家了。然后是一张这个男人按门铃的照片。然后你妻子和他出门了。然后他们去了一家酒店，我拍到了他们，看到他们在酒店前拥抱。然后他们进了酒店，我用长焦镜头拍到了房间。他们进了房间。脱掉了所有的衣服。然后他们拉上了窗帘。那人说，看见了吧？这就是我说的——那点疑虑。
[LAUGHING]
[笑声]
And I sort of feel like that in this story. Every time I come to a place, I have this element of doubt. And then it seems to clear up, and it seems not to. And so I am like the guy in the joke. I want to have it more certain.
我在这故事里也有这种感觉。每次我走到某个地方，我就会有这种怀疑。然后它似乎澄清了，又似乎没澄清。所以我就像笑话里那个人。我想要更确定。
The thing people always say is, well, you don't get a choice about your parents. And in a weird way, I have a choice. There's parts of me that wants my father to win and there's parts of me that wants Abie to win.
人们总是说，关于父母你没得选。但奇怪的是，我有一个选择。我内心有部分希望父亲获胜，也有部分希望Abie获胜。
Oh, really?
哦，真的吗？
Yeah.
是啊。
Which part what's your dad to win and which part wants Abie to win? What's the advantage of each?
哪部分希望你爸爸获胜，哪部分希望Abie获胜？各自有什么优势？
I guess the part that wants my father to win is the part that just wants to have that kind of consoling structure of you know your past. If you looked at home movies and you reran them and you saw yourself and your parents and you said, "Oh look, there's me and there are my parents and here is my father doing this or my mother doing that," as opposed to, if you reran them and you saw a person who wasn't your father, who knew on some level that he wasn't your father, trying to be your father-- it just complicates the whole issue. There's something about the continuity and the way you thought of yourself your whole life that you want to keep going.
我想希望父亲获胜的部分只是想要那种你了解过去后的安慰性结构。如果你翻看家庭电影，重温它们，你看到自己和父母说，“哦看，那是我和我的父母，这是我父亲在做这个，我母亲在做那个”，相比之下，如果你重温它们，看到一个不是你父亲的人，他心里知道他不是你父亲，却努力想当你的父亲——这只会使整个问题变得复杂。关于你一生对自己身份的认知及其连贯性，有些东西是你想要保留的。
The other side of that is I don't particularly like my father. He was a difficult man. He had an explosive temper. Like, if I cried, my father would laugh at me. He'd make fun of me for crying. He could be very intolerant. He would ridicule me and shame me. And that's a part that I wouldn't mind saying goodbye to or distancing myself from. Not that Abie was better, but it would allow me to detach myself from something that's sort of complicated and painful.
另一面是我并不特别喜欢我父亲。他是一个很难相处的人。他脾气暴躁。比如，如果我哭，父亲会嘲笑我。他会因为我哭而取笑我。他很不宽容。他会嘲笑我、羞辱我。那是我不介意告别或保持距离的部分。并不是说Abie更好，但这能让我脱离某种复杂且痛苦的东西。
Of course, at Lenny's age, what does detaching himself mean? He's already detached himself when he moved out at age 16. He detached himself when he went to college, when he made his own friends, when he found a wife, when he turned himself into an adult who's very different from either his dad or his uncle.
当然，以Lenny现在的年纪，脱离意味着什么？他在16岁搬出去时就已经脱离了。他上大学、交朋友、找妻子、把自己变成一个与父亲或叔叔截然不同的成年人时，就已经脱离了。
If you're 55, and you're fully formed, and your parents are long dead, and your own kids are actually completely grown, how much hold do your parents really have on you at that point? How much more independence from them can you possibly need? And yet somehow, even at that age, Lenny says it's still possible to daydream about the parents who you'd rather have had.
如果你55岁，心智完全成熟，父母早已去世，自己的孩子也长大成人了，那时父母对你到底有多大的掌控力？你还能需要从他们身上得到多大的独立性？然而在那个年纪，Lenny说依然可能幻想自己本应拥有的父母。
So if you got to choose-- if you got to imagine your dad going around and collecting other samples besides from your Uncle Abie, who would you want to choose?
所以如果你可以选择——如果你可以想象你爸爸去收集除Abie叔叔之外的其他样本，你会选谁？
Oh. Hm.
哦。嗯。
He can roam all of New York City in the year 1948. Who do you want him to stop by?
他可以在1948年漫游整个纽约市。你想要他在谁家停下来？
That's a good question. You know, two people are coming to mind. One was this guy who lived across the hall who was a-- he was a podiatrist and his name was Nathan Zuckerman. And he had an office a couple blocks away from where we lived. And in the office was the one room that was, like, the podiatrist room, and then there was the waiting room. And then there was what felt like 100 rooms back behind there with all kinds of electronic equipment.
这是个好问题。你知道，有两个人出现在我脑海里。一个是住在走廊对面的邻居，他是名足科医生，名字叫Nathan Zuckerman。他的诊所在离我们家几个街区的地方。办公室里有一个房间是足科诊疗室，还有一个候诊室。后面感觉还有100个房间，里面全是各种电子设备。
He was just an electronics hobbyist, like an old radio hobbyist?
他只是个电子爱好者，像个老无线电发烧友？
Yeah, exactly. Yeah. But I would just turn everything on and turn knobs and hear all kinds of whoa-oh-whoa-oh sounds. And I used to go there every day after school and just go in there. And there would be all these old ladies waiting for their bunions to be removed. Then I'd just go in the back and work on my science projects. He would come back and he would help me. It was really a nice relationship.
对，正是。但我会把所有东西都打开，转动旋钮，听各种“呜——”的声音。每天放学后我都会去那儿。候诊室里坐着等着切除鸡眼的老太太们。我就直接去后面做我的科学项目。他会回来帮我。那真的是一种很棒的关系。
And so if he were the guy, that would be good.
如果那个人是他，那该多好。
If he were the guy, yeah.
如果是他的话，是的。
Like the whole thing actually gives you solace in a way that it doesn't with Uncle Abie.
这就像整件事真的给你带来了一种Abie叔叔无法提供的安慰。
Yeah, exactly. I mean, if we only got to pick our parents.
对，没错。我是说，如果我们只能选择我们的父母的话。
Do you feel bad at all for thinking that it's possible that your dad isn't your dad?
因为觉得你爸爸可能不是你亲生父亲，你会感到难过吗？
Yeah, I really do. I mean, in a weird way, it feels like I'm doing the act of dis-parenting my father.
是的，真的很难过。从奇怪的角度看，这感觉就像我在剥夺我父亲的身份。
All right, I'll show you. I'm no longer going to be your son.
好吧，我要告诉你了。我不再做你的儿子了。
Right. Right. That feels definitely bad. That feels kind of mean.
对。对。那感觉真的很不好。感觉有点卑鄙。
Back in 2005, when we first broadcast today's show, Lenny met a guy named Wayne Grody, who was the doctor who ran the molecular diagnostic laboratory, the DNA lab, at UCLA. Grody told him that, for paternity tests, you want more DNA than is usually found on an envelope or a stamp. But Wayne also told him that there's often a really reliable source of DNA from people who have already died, and that's that, in most hospitals, when they take a biopsy or a tissue sample of any kind, they'll preserve a scrap of it in paraffin wax, just in case it'll be handy someday in reconfirming a diagnosis or in an epidemiological study or as part of a legal case.
2005年，当我们第一次播出今天的节目时，Lenny遇到了Wayne Grody，他是加州大学洛杉矶分校DNA实验室的主管。Grody告诉他，亲子鉴定需要的DNA比信封或邮票上通常发现的要多。但Wayne也告诉他，从已故的人身上通常能找到非常可靠的DNA来源，那就是在大多数医院，当他们取活检或任何类型的组织样本时，会把残余部分保存在石蜡中，以防日后重新确认诊断、流行病学研究或法律诉讼。
Wayne told Lenny to check with all the hospitals that his dad was ever in. So Lenny did. And he found a fragment of his dad's tissue from the 1970s at the Columbia Medical Center in New York. And then, before he knew it, Lenny was standing in Wayne Grody's DNA lab in California, talking to a lab technician named JJ.
Wayne建议Lenny联系他父亲曾经住过的所有医院。Lenny照做了。他在纽约哥伦比亚医学中心找到了他父亲1970年代的组织碎片。没过多久，Lenny就站在了加州的Wayne Grody DNA实验室里，与一位名叫JJ的实验室技术员谈话。
Your DNA actually is here.
你的DNA确实在这里。
Can I have a look?
能让我看看吗？
Yeah. Actually, it's very-- it's supposed to be clear.
可以。实际上它很——应该是清晰的。
It's just a tiny little bit. It looks like maybe, if I were crying, it would be about five tears.
只是一点点。看起来如果我当时在哭，大概也就是五滴眼泪那么多。
A technician named Dawn shows him another sample, which she insists is less like tears and more like a floating piece of lint. Then he's shown a little slice of wax the size of a fingernail with a little black line embedded in it. The line is tissue.
一位名叫Dawn的技术员给他看了另一个样本，她坚持说那看起来不像眼泪，更像是一块漂浮的棉絮。然后她给他看了切成指甲盖大小的蜡片，里面嵌着一条小黑线。那条线就是组织。
Let's see. That's the paraffin block?
让我看看。那就是石蜡块吗？
They cut it in slices, and this is one slice that I saved.
他们切成片，这是我保存的一片。
That's one slice? So that little piece of paraffin that you have there is where my father resides. So Dawn just kind of put that back in a little drawer under a desk. And that's where my dad is now-- in the drawer. He's in the drawer.
那是一片？所以你手里那小块石蜡就是我父亲居住的地方。Dawn把那东西放回书桌下的一个小抽屉里。这就是我父亲现在所在的地方——在抽屉里。他在抽屉里。
Dr. Grody warns Lenny that it could take weeks to get accurate results. And there's no guarantee, with tissue so old, they'll be able to salvage enough DNA to make a real determination if his dad is Uncle Abie or if his dad is Morris, the man he thought was his dad. Lenny goes home to wait. We give him a tape recorder to have on hand in case he gets any news. A month passes. Then a letter arrives.
Dr. Grody警告Lenny，得到准确结果可能需要数周。对于这么古老的组织，他们是否能提取足够的DNA来确定他父亲究竟是Abie叔叔还是他一直认为是父亲的Morris，并没有保证。Lenny回家等待。我们给了他一个录音机，以便他收到消息时能记录。一个月过去了。接着，一封信寄到了。
OK, let's put this in context here. The envelope arrived today. It's sitting right over here. And I'm looking at it, and I know that inside this envelope is the answer. I'm going to find out who my father is, or if my father is my father. The answer is sitting right there in the envelope. And I am really nervous right now. I'm kind of excited about it. I'm kind of dreading it. OK. Let's see.
好了，我们要交代一下背景。信今天到了。就在这儿。我看着它，我知道信封里有答案。我要知道谁是我的父亲，或者我父亲是否真的是我的父亲。答案就在信封里。我现在非常紧张。既有些兴奋，又有些恐惧。好了。看看吧。
[ENVELOPE TEARING]
[撕信封声]
Whoa, this is scary. It says, "I'm writing to tell you--" it's from Wayne. He says, "I'm writing to tell you that we have now concluded--" I almost can't read this. This is really weird. I'm getting very scared about this. "We have now concluded paternity testing." Blah, blah, blah. "The results indicate that Mr-- Morris is excluded as a possible father of yours." There's all the rest that I'm not going to even read that.
哇，这太吓人了。它写着，“我写信告诉你——”是Wayne来的信。他说，“我写信告诉你，我们现在已经完成了亲子鉴定。”巴拉巴拉。我简直读不下去。这太诡异了。我对此感到非常害怕。“我们现在已经完成了亲子鉴定。”剩下的我就不读了。
So my father is not my father. Morris is not my father.
所以我父亲不是我父亲。Morris不是我父亲。
[SIGH]
[叹息]
It makes me feel really sad. My father is not my father.
我感到非常难过。我父亲不是我父亲。
[SIGH]
[叹息]
There's a part of me that's going like, I knew it. But there it is. It's just in definitive print. "Results indicate that Mr. Morris," it says, "is excluded as a possible father of yours by mismatches we have observed." And it says that, "We find a DNA pattern in the child which is not present in that of the alleged father, meaning that it must have been contributed by another man." Wow.
我内心有部分在说，我知道会这样。但这确实摆在这里。它是白纸黑字。“结果显示Morris先生，”上面写着，“被排除在你亲生父亲的可能之外，因为我们观察到了不匹配。”上面还写着，“我们在孩子身上发现了DNA模式，但据称的父亲身上却没有，这意味着它必须是由另一个男人提供的。”哇。
[SIGH]
[叹息]
I guess I feel abandoned. I know that doesn't make any sense. But I feel like I was abandoned by my father.
我想我感到被抛弃了。我知道这没道理。但我感觉就像被父亲抛弃了一样。
Then there's this next wave of feeling that's coming up, and it's like, aha, see? That was right. I was right. The feelings I had of not being part of my family, of being the one who was just bad for being the other is true. That really is true. That was going through their heads. And my father had this really tough row to hoe.
接着下一波情绪涌了上来，就是，啊哈，看见了吗？那是对的。我是对的。我感觉自己不属于那个家庭、仅仅因为作为另一个“我”而显得格格不入的感觉是真的。那真的是真的。他们内心确实是那么想的。我父亲走过了一段艰难的路。
And I'm sort of feeling sorry for him, really, knowing what he went through, how difficult that was, and all the pretense and trying to rise above it and be noble. I feel like he did a great job on that. He really did, in the sense that he never let me know. He just kept the secret, both of them. They went to their graves without even letting me know.
我开始为他感到难过，真的，知道他经历了什么，那有多困难，所有的伪装，试图超越这一切并保持高尚。我觉得他做得很好。真的，因为他从来没让我知道。他只是保守了这个秘密，他们俩。他们带着秘密入土，甚至没告诉我。
And they must have thought, there's no way he's ever going to know. And now I know. Now, at 55 years old, I know that Morris is not my father. In a weird way, I almost feel better about him for that.
他们一定认为，我永远也不会知道。现在我知道了。现在，在55岁时，我知道Morris不是我父亲。从奇怪的角度看，我甚至因为这一点而对他感觉好了一点。
[SIGH]
[叹息]
A week after he opened the letter, Lenny came back into the studio. And he told me that the DNA test showed something else that was completely unexpected. There are six genetic markers that would have indicated paternity. Lenny's dad only had a match on one of those. If he were Lenny's uncle, you'd expect he'd have three matches, since brothers share half their DNA. And this raises a whole new question.
在打开信的一周后，Lenny回到演播室。他告诉我，DNA检测显示了完全意想不到的结果。有六个遗传标记可以指示亲子关系。Lenny的父亲只匹配了一个。如果他是Lenny的叔叔，你应该预期会有三个匹配，因为兄弟分享一半DNA。这引发了一个全新的问题。
I had been operating on the assumption that, if my father wasn't my father, then my uncle was my father, and that, if my uncle was my father, my father was my uncle-- which, of course, sounds like some kind of camp song. It's still statistically possible that my uncle could be my father, but, in fact, it's probably more likely that there was another donor.
我之前的假设是，如果父亲不是我亲生父亲，那么叔叔就是我父亲；如果叔叔是我父亲，父亲就是我叔叔——这听起来像某种营火歌。我叔叔是我父亲在统计学上仍有可能，但事实上，很可能还有另一个捐赠者。
And who might that have been? Just somebody who worked at the hospital?
那个人可能是谁？医院工作的某个人？
It could have been anybody. I mean, if this was done in a hospital-- it probably wasn't. It was probably done in a doctor's office. And one of the standard things that happened back in 1949, '48, was that the doctor himself sometimes was the donor, or sometimes it could have been a medical student.
可能是任何人。如果这是在医院做的——可能并不是。可能是在医生办公室做的。1949、1948年发生的事情之一，有时医生本人就是捐赠者，或者有时可能是医学生。
Lenny, both your parents have been dead for decades, but if what you're saying is right, you might have a living parent, like, in New York right now.
Lenny，你的父母都去世了几十年，但如果你的说法是对的，你现在在纽约可能还有一位健在的亲生父亲。
Yeah.
是的。
Knowing that he could be out there and alive, your actual dad, doesn't that make you want to find him?
知道他可能还在世，你的亲生父亲，这难道不想让你去找他吗？
No. In a way, I'd just like him to kind of wander along in his life and let me wander along in mine. I think I've had enough parents. I think I know enough now. I don't think I need to know more.
不。从某种程度上，我只想让他过他自己的生活，让我过我的。我想我已经有足够多的父母了。我想我现在知道得够多了。我想我不需要知道更多了。
Which is to say, in the end, it doesn't matter as much to Lenny who his father is as who his father isn't.
也就是说，最终，对于Lenny来说，谁是他的父亲不如谁不是他的父亲重要。
From the day that Lenny's Uncle Abie first told him on the phone about his father to the day that Lenny got the letter where the other shoe dropped, it was 24 years. And in the recording that he made that day, Lenny talked about how one of the strangest things about the whole experience was that now he couldn't go and talk to the people who he most needs to talk to about the whole thing.
从Abie叔叔在电话里告诉他关于父亲的那天，到Lenny收到信靴子落地的那天，过去了24年。在他那天制作的录音中，Lenny谈到这种经历中最奇怪的事情之一就是，他现在没法去和最需要谈论这件事的人谈谈了。
This is even made so much stranger by the fact that my mother and father are dead. And I should be able to go over and see them and say, so what was this all about? And I would say, it's OK. I think I'd actually end up comforting them, in a weird way. You did all right. You did what you had to do. You did what the doctors told you to do. You thought that keeping the secret forever-- that it would be devastating for me to find out. But I would say, I'm not devastated. I still love you. I love you very much.
这更显得荒谬的事实是我的父母已经去世了。我本该去见见他们，问问这到底是怎么回事？我会说，没关系。我想我其实会反过来安慰他们，以一种奇怪的方式。你们做得很好。你们做了必须做的事。你们照医生说的做了。你们认为保守那个秘密直到永远——我发现真相会让我崩溃。但我会说，我没有崩溃。我仍然爱你们。我非常爱你们。
And I guess, if I were really being honest, then I would say, but you didn't have to. You could have let me just grow up the way I would have. You didn't have to try to shape me and change me so I wouldn't be like Abie. And you didn't have to fear the difference that you would see in me.
我想，如果我真的诚实，我会说，但你们不必如此。你们可以让我按自己的方式成长。你们不必试图塑造我、改变我，好让我不像Abie。你们不必害怕在我身上看到的那些不同。
And then I think I would just say thank you. Thank you for doing the impossible and for having me. And then probably we'd just get into a fight with each other or something. Or just go have some really bad food that my mother made.
然后我想我会说谢谢。谢谢你们完成了不可能的任务，让我来到这个世界。然后可能我们会互相吵一架什么的。或者只是去吃点我母亲做的难吃的食物。
Lenny Davis is a distinguished professor of English at the University of Illinois in Chicago. In the years since we first broadcast this story, he's had additional genetic testing that shows that, indeed, Uncle Abie is most likely his dad. He wrote a book about his experience. It's called Go Ask Your Father.
Lenny Davis是伊利诺伊大学芝加哥分校的杰出英语教授。自我们首次播出这个故事以来的几年里，他又进行了额外的基因检测，结果确实显示Abie叔叔很可能是他的父亲。他写了一本关于这段经历的书。书名是《去问你父亲》。
Coming up, a dad in one of the most misunderstood, maligned professions in the world. And no, I'm not talking about insurance salesman, car salesman, lawyer, telephone solicitor, or member of the United States Congress. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，一位从事世界上最被误解、最被诋毁职业的父亲。不，我不是说保险推销员、汽车销售、律师、电话推销员或美国国会议员。一会儿回来揭晓，芝加哥公共广播电台，节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, which we first broadcast years ago, back in 2005, Go Ask Your Father, stories in which grown people seek answers from their own parents. And there definitely are certain answers that they would prefer to hear, and only sometimes do they get them.
这是《美国生活》。我是Ira Glass。每周节目，我们都会选择一个主题，为您带来各种相关的不同故事。今天的节目，我们几年前，也就是2005年首次播出，主题是《去问你父亲》，讲述成年人从父母那里寻求答案的故事。他们肯定希望听到某些答案，但只有有时他们才能如愿。
We have arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, My Favorite Martian. Paul Tough tells the story.
节目第二幕。第二幕，我最爱的火星人。Paul Tough讲述这个故事。
This is a story about fathers and sons. And it is a story about communication with alien beings. It begins in the 1820s in Germany, where an astronomer and mathematician named Carl Friedrich Gauss was working as the director of the observatory in the town of Gottingen. After the death of, first, one wife, and then a second, he began to spend every evening at the observatory, staring up through his telescope at the moon and the stars.
这是一个关于父子的故事。也是关于与外星生命交流的故事。它始于1820年代的德国，当时一位名叫Carl Friedrich Gauss的天文学家兼数学家担任哥廷根天文台台长。在失去第一任妻子，随后又失去第二任妻子后，他开始每晚待在天文台，透过望远镜凝视月亮和星星。
Could it be, he wondered on those lonely nights, that, far away in those distant specks of light, there was life? That people just like him were staring back through their own telescopes?
他在那些孤独的夜晚思索，会不会在那遥远的光点中存在着生命？是不是有人就像他一样，也正透过自己的望远镜回望呢？
Since the first moment that humans began dreaming of communicating with beings from other worlds, there have been two schools of thought on how best to go about it. One strategy is simply to observe, to look through telescopes, to listen to radio waves beaming down at us from space. The second is the active approach, to try to make contact ourselves.
自人类开始梦想与来自其他世界的生物交流的第一刻起，关于如何实现目标的理论就分成了两派。一种策略仅仅是观察，透过望远镜看，聆听从太空射向我们的无线电波。第二种是主动的方法，尝试我们自己建立联系。
Gauss was the first person to suggest this latter approach, to say that it was we who should make contact with them. But how? This question is hard enough to answer today, when we've got rocket ships and lasers and transistor radios. Gauss lived in an era of sextants and quill pens and leeches, none of which were very useful when it came to sending messages into space. So remember those limitations when I describe Gauss' two proposals, which might sound a little crude.
Gauss是第一个提出后者的人，认为应该是我们主动联系他们。但怎么联系呢？今天当我们有了火箭、激光和晶体管收音机时，这个问题都很难回答。Gauss生活在一个只有六分仪、鹅毛笔和水蛭的时代，当涉及到发送信息到太空时，这些都没什么用。所以，当你听到我描述Gauss的两个提案时，请记住这些局限性，它们听起来可能有点原始。
Idea one, deploy an army of Russian lumberjacks to clear cut thousands of square miles of Siberian forest in the precise shape of a right triangle, with huge markings along each side demonstrating the Pythagorean theorem.
方案一，派遣一支俄罗斯伐木工军队，在西伯利亚森林中开辟出几千平方公里的精确直角三角形，边上用巨大的标记展示毕达哥拉斯定理。
Idea two, dig a giant, circular trench in the Sahara Desert hundreds of miles in diameter, a perfect circle. Fill the trench with millions of gallons of kerosene. Wait until nightfall, and then set it on fire.
方案二，在撒哈拉沙漠中挖一个直径几百英里的巨大圆形沟渠，一个完美的圆。向沟渠里灌注几百万加仑煤油。等待夜幕降临，然后点火。
But no one would spring for the kerosene, and so Gauss turned his attention back to non-Euclidean geometry. And for 150 years, no one had a single good idea. Then rocketry was invented, and Alan Shepard played golf on the moon. And all of a sudden, the stars seemed closer than ever.
但没人愿意为煤油买单，所以Gauss转而研究非欧几何了。在随后的150年里，没人有一个好主意。然后火箭发明了，Alan Shepard在月球上打了高尔夫球。突然间，星星看起来比以往任何时候都近。
Over at NASA, somebody had a brainstorm. Let's send the aliens a plaque. So in April 1973, Pioneer 11 was launched into space, and bolted onto it was a gold plaque. Maybe you've seen it. It's got a diagram of the solar system, some mathematical notations, and a drawing of a naked Caucasian woman and man, the man with his right hand raised at a 90 degree angle.
在NASA，有人有了个奇思妙想。给外星人发块匾吧。于是1973年4月，先驱者11号发射升空，上面镶嵌了一块金匾。也许你见过。上面有太阳系的图表、一些数学符号，还有一幅裸体的白人女性和男性的画像，男人抬起右手，呈90度角。
32 years later, this calling card is more than 4 billion miles from Earth, at the outer regions of our solar system. At some point, maybe tomorrow, maybe in 100 million years, someone will find Pioneer 11, or so the theory goes. And when they see the plaque, they will get the message. Greetings from planet Earth. This is what we look like. We are waving hello to you, and we are nude.
32年后，这张名片距离地球超过40亿英里，处于我们太阳系的外围。在某个时刻，也许是明天，也许是一亿年后，有人会找到先驱者11号，理论是这么说的。当他们看到匾时，他们会收到信息。来自地球的问候。这就是我们的样子。我们在招手问候，而且我们是裸体的。
In 1974, a year after the launch of Pioneer 11, an American astronomer named Frank Drake took the next step and sent a radio message into space, beamed from a giant radio telescope in Puerto Rico and aimed at a star cluster 21,000 light years away. The message was a series of ones and zeros that could be rearranged to form a diagram that showed a stick figure of a human. Innocuous enough, it would seem.
1974年，先驱者11号发射一年后，美国天文学家Frank Drake迈出了下一步，向太空发送了一条无线电信息，从波多黎各的一个巨型射电望远镜射出，瞄准21000光年外的一个星团。信息是一系列0和1，可以重新排列成一个显示人类火柴人的图表。这看起来足够无害。
And yet, Drake's message drove the astronomy establishment completely crazy. International rules were drawn up, and since that day, no official radio message has ever been sent into space. But that doesn't mean that freelancers have quit trying to make contact on their own. They have not. And I can tell you this because one of them is my father.
然而，Drake的信息让天文学界彻底疯了。国际规则被制定出来，从那以后，官方再没向太空发送过无线电信息。但这并不意味着自由职业者已经停止尝试建立联系。他们没有。我能告诉你这一点，因为其中一位就是我的父亲。
In the mid-1970s, my father, a mild-mannered university professor, concluded that there had to be more to life than commuting to work every day in his red Toyota Corolla and coming home every night to the quiet house on the sleepy street where his family was waiting for him. When he was about the age I am today, he started looking for something new, experimenting with LSD and open marriage and extrasensory perception and listening over and over to Pink Floyd's Dark Side of the Moon, until finally, at about the time that Frank Drake was beaming his lonely message out into space, my father left his family behind and set off onto uncharted waters.
1970年代中期，我父亲，一名温文尔雅的大学教授，断定生活中应该不仅仅是每天开着那辆红色丰田花冠车上下班，每天晚上回到那个安静的街道、家人等待的家里。当他长到我现在这个岁数时，他开始寻找新事物，尝试LSD、开放婚姻和超感官知觉，反复听Pink Floyd的《月之暗面》，直到最后，在大约Frank Drake向太空发送孤独信息的时候，父亲抛下家庭，踏入了未知的领域。
From this description, my father might sound like a real Peter Fonda type. But in fact, he is anything but. He is a lover of office products, a man who thinks there is no decision, no matter how intimate and emotional, that cannot be made more effectively by drawing up a few lists and charts. At one point, a couple of years into his relationship with the woman he lived with after moving out of our house, he explained to me that he had come up with a system to eliminate the arguments that had begun to crop up between the two of them. If they had a disagreement-- let's say about what they wanted to eat for dinner-- they would each simply assign a number out of 10 to how strongly they felt about their preference. So their conversations included sentences like, "I'm a seven on chicken." If his number was higher than hers, they'd have chicken.
从这段描述看，我父亲可能听起来像个真正的Peter Fonda式的叛逆者。但事实恰恰相反。他是办公用品的狂热爱好者，一个认为没有决定——无论多么私密和情感化——不能通过列出几张清单和图表来更有效地解决的人。有一次，在与搬出家后住在一起的那个女人交往几年后，他向我解释说他想出了一个系统来消除两人之间开始出现的争吵。如果他们有分歧——比方说晚餐想吃什么——他们每个人只需给自己的倾向打分（满分10分）。所以他们的对话里出现了类似“我对吃鸡肉打7分”这样的句子。如果他的分数比她高，他们就吃鸡肉。
It might seem a little strange that a man who often has trouble making contact with the human beings around him has focused his energies on attempts to make contact with extraterrestrials. Strange, and at the same time, entirely fitting. Over the last few years, my father has been building his own giant flaming moat of kerosene. It is a page on the world wide web, and it is titled, "An Invitation to ETI," which stands for Extraterrestrial Intelligence.
对于一个经常难以与身边人建立联系的人来说，把精力集中在尝试与外星人接触上似乎有点奇怪。奇怪，但同时又非常合适。过去几年里，我父亲一直在修建他自己的巨大燃烧煤油的护城河。那是一个网页，标题是“给ETI的邀请函”，ETI代表地外智慧生命。
This is how the page reads. "Hello, ETI. We assume you are a highly advanced form of alien intelligence that originally came to Earth from some other place in the universe. We welcome you here. With respect and a spirit of friendship, we invite you to make contact. Feel free to use whatever form of communication you prefer-- email, fax, telephone, or a face-to-face conversation."
网页是这样写的。“你好，ETI。我们假设你们是一种高度先进的外星智能，最初从宇宙中某个地方来到地球。欢迎来到这里。带着尊重和友谊的精神，我们邀请你们建立联系。请随意使用你们偏好的任何交流方式——电子邮件、传真、电话或面对面交流。”
It's easy to make fun of my father's project, but there is a logic to it, as unlikely as it sounds. A series of premises, each of which, taken alone, makes a certain sense. My father is right that there probably is life somewhere else in the universe. If other civilizations have developed, they probably are a lot more advanced than we are. He has a point when he says that there's no particular reason to assume that extraterrestrials would choose to communicate via radio signals. He can even be convincing when he says that these alien civilizations might instead have sent probes to our planet to monitor us and our communication media, including the internet.
取笑我父亲的项目很容易，但正如其听起来不可思议的那样，它是有逻辑的。这一系列前提，每一个单独来看都有一定道理。我父亲认为宇宙中某处可能存在生命是对的。如果其他文明已经发展，他们可能比我们先进得多。他说没有特别理由假设外星人会选择通过无线电信号交流，这一点也有道理。当他说这些外星文明可能派遣了探测器到我们星球来监测我们和我们的通讯媒介（包括互联网）时，他甚至很有说服力。
It's only when you put it all together, when you're actually sitting there, staring at the fax machine, waiting for the alien message to arrive, that the project suddenly seems a little dubious. In five years, my father has received about 60 messages through his website, and they were all pranks-- emails from smart alecks who thought it might be a good chuckle to impersonate an alien for a while.
只有当你把这一切加在一起，当你真的坐在传真机前，等待外星信息到来时，这个项目突然显得有点可疑。五年里，我父亲通过网站收到了大约60条信息，全部是恶作剧——来自那些觉得冒充外星人玩一阵子很有趣的聪明家伙。
My father wrote back to all 60 of them, asking them for proof that they were really aliens. A couple of them kept the charade going for a few rounds, but eventually they all gave up and admitted they were only human.
我父亲给所有60个人回了信，要求他们提供是外星人的证明。其中几个人维持了几个回合的欺诈，但最终都放弃并承认他们只是人类。
And then, late last year, a breakthrough. In November, my father received an email from a man named Harold, who seemed different than the jokers he usually heard from. Harold didn't claim to be an extraterrestrial. Instead, he said, he had obtained physical evidence of alien life and he was offering to submit it to rigorous scientific testing. This evidence, he explained, was an alien probe, an energy field embedded in his body. He said that it emitted radio waves that could be detected by conventional instruments.
然后，去年年底，有了突破。11月，父亲收到了一封名叫Harold的男人的邮件，他看起来与往常的玩笑者不同。Harold没声称自己是外星人。相反，他说他获得了外星生命的物理证据，并提出愿意将其提交给严格的科学测试。他解释说，这个证据是一个外星探测器，一个嵌入他身体里的能量场。他说它发出的无线电波可以被常规仪器检测到。
My father was skeptical, but intrigued. He talked it over by email with the board of advisors he had assembled when he set up his website, and they decided that, for the first time in the history of this project, they should put an alien claim to the test. Which is how I wound up driving out to a warehouse in New Jersey one winter morning to meet my father, who had flown down from Toronto for the day.
父亲持怀疑态度，但很感兴趣。他通过邮件与他在建立网站时组建的顾问委员会进行了商讨，他们决定，这个项目历史上第一次，应该对一个外星人的声称进行测试。这就是我那个冬天的早晨开车去新泽西一个仓库见父亲的原因，他那天特意从多伦多飞过来。
I went because I wanted to see my father at work, because I thought it might give me a chance to connect to a part of his life that meant a lot to him, even if I didn't really understand just why. It also crossed my mind that, if evidence of alien life was going to be found in suburban New Jersey, it wouldn't hurt to be the one guy there with a tape recorder.
我去是因为我想看父亲工作，因为我觉得这也许能让我有机会接触他生命中对他意义重大的那一部分，尽管我并不真正理解为什么。我还想到，如果外星生命证据真的要在新泽西郊区被发现，那带上录音机去现场准没错。
[CAR DOOR CLOSING]
[关车门声]
Hey, Dad.
嘿，爸爸。
Hi.
嗨。
How's it going?
进展如何？
Good.
好。
When I first spotted my father, he looked a little weak and off balance. A couple of years ago, he was diagnosed with Parkinson's disease. And although it hasn't incapacitated him yet, he gets tired easily these days. It affects the way he talks, too. Sometimes he has to start a word three times before he finishes it once.
第一次看到父亲时，他看起来有点虚弱和不稳定。几年前，他被诊断出患有帕金森病。虽然还没让他丧失行动能力，但他最近很容易疲劳。这也影响了他的谈话方式。有时他得把一个词说三次才能说完整。
But he seemed glad to be there, catching up with two members of his advisory board who were also there for the test. One, named Paul, was an aerospace engineer, a bearded, energetic man who laughed a lot. The other, Richard, was tall and laconic, with long, gray hair. He owned his own electronics firm, and it was his warehouse where we were going to run the test.
但他很高兴能在那儿，和同样来测试的两位顾问委员会成员叙旧。一位叫Paul，是位航空航天工程师，蓄着胡子，充满活力，爱笑。另一位Richard，身材高大且寡言，灰发长发。他拥有自己的电子公司，测试就在他的仓库里进行。
It was nice to watch these guys interact with my dad. They looked up to him, in a way. There was no sign of Harold, and for a while, we thought maybe he wouldn't show up. But then he walked in and launched right into what sounded like a prepared speech.
看着这些人和我父亲互动很愉快。他们某种程度上很尊敬他。现场不见Harold的踪影，我们一度以为他不会来了。但随后他走了进来，直接开始了他听起来像是准备好的演讲。
But I have a little presentation. Do we have a chalkboard? Or paper?
我有一个简短的介绍。我们有黑板吗？或者纸？
Harold is wearing baggy khaki pants and a white Oxford shirt that looked like it had been packed inside a duffel bag for a few days and then unfolded that morning. He had a kind of '40s hat on-- not a fedora, but a round hat, more casual, almost a fishing hat. He was clean-shaven and olive-skinned and animated. We all followed him into the library for his presentation.
Harold穿着松垮的卡其裤和一件白色牛津衬衫，看起来像是被塞进行李袋好几天，那天早上才展开的。他戴着一顶40年代风格的帽子——不是软呢帽，而是一顶圆帽，更休闲，几乎像是钓鱼帽。他刮了胡子，橄榄色的皮肤，生动活泼。我们都跟着他进入图书馆参加他的演讲。
And I'm going to do a demonstration with an RF detector to show that I am emitting radio frequencies. And exactly how, why, and where they're going, we will determine in the lab.
我将用RF（射频）检测器进行演示，以显示我正在发射无线电频率。至于它们究竟是如何、为什么以及去向何处，我们将在实验室里确定。
What he was saying-- that he himself was emitting radio signals that were being monitored by an alien spaceship-- didn't make a whole lot of sense. But there was something about the way he was talking. He acted just like a scientist. He had the lingo down, saying things like "gigahertz" and "RF" instead of "radio frequency." And when he drew diagrams on the whiteboard, they looked convincing, full of vectors and arrows and numbers. Then he started unpacking his equipment.
他说的那些——他自己正在发射无线电信号，并被外星飞船监测——并没有多大意义。但他说话的方式有些特别。他表现得就像个科学家。他掌握了术语，说的是“千兆赫”和“RF”而不是“无线电频率”。当他在白板上画图时，看起来很有说服力，全是向量、箭头和数字。然后他开始打开他的设备。
At this point, I'll demonstrate the radio frequency.
在这一点上，我将演示无线电频率。
He removed a Tupperware container from his knapsack and revealed a little device that looked like a computer circuit board, about 2 inches long. Then he put it into his mouth.
他从背包里拿出一个特百惠容器，露出了一个看起来像计算机电路板的小装置，大约2英寸长。然后他把它放进嘴里。
[RAPID BEEPING]
[快速哔哔声]
It started to make noise.
它开始发出声音。
What you have just seen is the activation of an RF detector by transmission from an electric field anomaly placed next to my vocal cords that it transmits back to the extraterrestrials.
你刚才看到的是RF检测器的激活，通过放置在我声带旁边的电场异常传输，它将其回传给外星人。
I looked over at my father to try to figure out what he made of all this, but it was hard to tell just what he was thinking. And then it was time for the test. We all went downstairs to the lab, which was equipped with a huge radio wave detector. The idea was that it would measure the waves coming out of Harold's head. Richard talked him through it.
我看向父亲试图弄明白他对这一切怎么看，但很难说他在想什么。接着到了测试时间。我们都去了楼下的实验室，配备了一个巨大的无线电波检测器。思路是它将测量从Harold头部发出的波。Richard指导他进行测试。
I guess the next step is for you to go in the room. Would you care to remove your hat first, please?
我想下一步是你进那个房间。请问你能先脱掉帽子吗？
Oh, sure.
哦，当然。
You can't hear it on the tape, but this was a really awkward moment. When Harold took off his hat, we could see that he had lined the inside with tinfoil-- a tinfoil hat. It's like a cliche, right? A shorthand term for crazy people who believe in aliens. I'd seen tinfoil hats in movies, but I didn't know they existed in real life.
你录音里听不到，但这真的是个非常尴尬的瞬间。Harold脱下帽子时，我们看到他里面衬了铝箔——铝箔帽。就像个陈词滥调，对吧？那是相信外星人的疯子的简称。我在电影里见过铝箔帽，但没想到现实中真有。
I use that because sometimes the radio signals really affect me.
我用它是为了因为有时无线电信号真的会影响我。
I can imagine. Do you have anything with you? Any devices, anything made of metal?
我可以想象。你身上有什么吗？任何设备，任何金属做的东西？
Yes, I have some foil on my chest.
是的，我的胸部贴了一些铝箔。
OK. Just plain aluminum foil?
好的。只是普通的铝箔？
Yes. Yeah. Is that all right to bring in there?
是的。对。带进那里面没问题吧？
If that's all it is.
如果只是那个的话。
Yeah, that's all it is.
对，只有那个。
You don't have any artifacts--
你没有其他人工制品——
After the tinfoil thing, it wasn't such a big surprise when the lab's equipment failed to detect any radio waves being emitted from the probe in Harold's head. Harold was clearly upset that the experiment hadn't worked, and he made excuses and explained how maybe we needed more sensitive equipment. Paul and Richard, the scientists, seemed a bit ticked off by the whole experience.
在铝箔事情之后，当实验室设备未能检测到Harold头部探测器发出的无线电波时，也就没什么好奇怪的了。Harold显然对实验没成功感到不安，他找借口并解释说也许我们需要更灵敏的设备。Paul和Richard两位科学家被整个过程搞得有点恼火。
But my dad wasn't worked up at all. He thanked Harold, shook his hand, and gave him some money for his bus trip home. I wasn't quite sure what to feel. I was a little disappointed, despite myself. I did feel like I had shared some history with my father, even if it wasn't the Pulitzer Prize-winning kind. But I still didn't really understand just what it was that had brought us here.
但我父亲一点也不激动。他感谢了Harold，握了握手，给了他一些回家的公交车费。我不太确定自己该有什么感觉。尽管我不愿意，但我还是感到有些失望。我确实觉得我和父亲分享了一些历史，即使那不是普利策奖级别的那种。但我仍然不明白到底是什么把我们带到了这里。
So after Harold left, I sat down with my father on an office couch just off the library. And I finally got a chance to ask him about some things I had never really understood about his quest, including what seemed like an unavoidable question for anyone in the field of SETI, which is what insiders call the Search for Extraterrestrial Intelligence.
所以Harold离开后，我和父亲坐在图书馆旁边办公室的沙发上。我终于有机会问他一些我从未真正理解的关于他追求的事，包括对外星文明搜寻（SETI）领域的每个人来说似乎不可避免的一个问题，也就是内幕人士称之为搜寻外星智能。
Do you think people think of SETI as a joke sometimes?
你觉得人们有时把SETI当作笑话吗？
Yeah, we called it the "giggle factor" in SETI. Sure.
是的，我们在SETI里称之为“嗤笑因素”。当然。
And why do you think that is?
你觉得为什么会这样？
Haven't figured it out. I feel it myself, you know? I can't always keep a straight face when I tell people what I do.
没想出来。我自己也感觉得到，你知道吗？我告诉别人我做这行时，不能总是保持严肃表情。
Really?
真的吗？
Sure.
当然。
Well, how come?
嗯，为什么？
It just is funny to be trying to make contact with another culture, when we don't even know whether it exists or not.
试图与另一种文化建立联系本身就很滑稽，当我们甚至不知道它是否存在时。
Is there any other scientific field that is like that?
有什么其他科学领域是这样的吗？
I can't think of one where the field hasn't even proved that its central phenomenon exists.
我想不出哪个领域甚至还没证明其核心现象的存在。
That's true. When you look at it that way, it's pretty dramatic.
是真的。如果你那样看它，它确实非常戏剧性。
It's the thing I sometimes forget about my dad. He doesn't have a lot of illusions about how likely it is that aliens will get in touch anytime soon. I think it's the reason why he didn't seem all that disappointed when Harold struck out in the lab. He's prepared to keep waiting.
这就是我有时会忘记关于我父亲的一点。他对 aliens 很快会联系的可能性并没有太多幻想。我想这就是为什么他在Harold在实验室失败时看起来并没有那么失望的原因。他准备好继续等待。
But I can't help feeling that there is something a little sad about any search for extraterrestrial intelligence, whether it's Carl Friedrich Gauss' or my father's. It seems like a quest born out of a great loneliness, out of the feeling that the life we see around us is not enough. It is a feeling-- a longing, really-- not that different than the way a frustrated husband and father might feel coming back to the same predictable home night after night. It is the feeling that there must be more than this.
但我无法抑制地感到，对于任何寻找地外智慧生命的探索——无论是Carl Friedrich Gauss的还是我父亲的——都有点悲伤。这看起来像是一种因巨大孤独感而生的探索，一种觉得周围所见的生活不足够的感觉。这是一种感觉——真的，一种渴望——与一个因厌倦而晚上夜复一夜回到同样可预测家庭的丈夫和父亲的感觉没什么不同。这是一种感觉，觉得生活中必须有更多东西。
If I thought that this was all-- that what's on Earth is all that there is in the universe, I'd be-- I would feel that the universe was diminished somehow. I sometimes get accused of expecting a savior. I don't think I'm doing that. But it certainly comes close to religious belief because you're dealing with something that's just so big, so overarching, so transcendent, that it's pretty close to what a lot of people call God.
如果我认为这就是全部——地球上所拥有的就是宇宙中所有的东西，我会——我会觉得宇宙以某种方式缩小了。我有时被指责在期待救世主。我不认为我在那样做。但它肯定接近宗教信仰，因为你在处理一些非常庞大、全面、超然的东西，这非常接近许多人所说的上帝。
For me, the difference is that ET could exist. I don't see how God could exist. It just sounds too fantastic.
对我来说，区别在于ET可能存在。我不明白上帝怎么可能存在。那听起来太虚幻了。
Do you think this project is the most meaningful thing you've ever done?
你认为这个项目是你做过最有意义的事情吗？
Yes, I think it is. Yep. In fact, my shorthand nickname for it is "The Ultimate Project" because it's probably my ultimate project. I've called it that from the start.
是的，我想是。Yep。事实上，我给它取的速记昵称是“终极项目”，因为这大概就是我的终极项目。从一开始我就这么叫它。
If I'm going to be honest with you, I should probably say that that's not the answer I wanted him to give. I wanted him to say, sure, maybe it's the most meaningful thing I've done professionally. But it doesn't compare to raising my family, to being a father.
如果我要对你诚实，我可能得说那不是我想要的答案。我希望他说，当然，也许这是我在专业上做过最有意义的事情。但这无法与抚养家庭、做一个父亲相比。
I think any child of an eccentric father feels two opposing things simultaneously. Mostly, you want him to stop embarrassing you. When he sends you an email, you want the subject header to be something normal like, "Thanksgiving plans." You don't want subject headers like the one I received from my father the other day-- "What if our galaxy is populated by super-smart machines?"
我想任何有一个古怪父亲的孩子都会同时感受到两种相反的情绪。大部分时间，你希望他别再让你尴尬。当他给你发邮件时，你希望主题行是像“感恩节计划”这样正常的。你不希望看到那种我父亲前几天给我发的——“如果我们的银河系住满了超级智能机器怎么办？”
But at the same time, the thought of my dad dismantling his website and giving up his dream feels like a terrible loss. Even if my father's project doesn't make a whole lot of sense to me, even if it sometimes feels more like prayer than like science, I want him to keep looking. It makes him seem a little less alien, oddly enough, and a little more human.
但与此同时，想到父亲拆除网站并放弃梦想，感觉像是一种巨大的损失。即使父亲的项目对我来说没太大意义，即使它有时感觉更像是祈祷而不是科学，我还是希望他继续寻找。奇怪的是，这让他看起来不像那么外星人，而更像一个普通人。
Paul Tough is one of the original contributing editors to This American Life. Since this story first aired in 2005, his father found out that he suffered from multiple system atrophy, not Parkinson's disease. In 2012, he died from complications related to that disorder.
Paul Tough是《美国生活》的创始特约编辑之一。自这个故事2005年首次播出以来，他的父亲发现自己患有多系统萎缩症，而不是帕金森病。2012年，他因该疾病引发的并发症去世。
Before he died, he asked that Paul and Paul's sister keep his website going, and they plan to do that indefinitely, even though neither of them are as hopeful about it as Paul's dad was. As of today, they have yet to receive any messages from extraterrestrials. But, you know, if you're hearing my voice right now and you come from another planet, or you know somebody who does, you can make contact at www.ieti-- that's invitation to extraterrestrial intelligence-- ieti.org.
他去世前，请求Paul和Paul的姐姐继续运营他的网站，他们打算无限期地运营下去，尽管他们都不像Paul的父亲那么抱有希望。截至今日，他们尚未收到任何外星人的信息。但是，如果你现在听到我的声音，你来自另一个星球，或者认识来自那里的某个人，你可以通过www.ieti——也就是邀请地外智慧生命，ieti.org建立联系。
Paul's latest book is Helping Children Succeed, What Works and Why. He first read a version of today's story at the Little Gray Books lecture series in New York City.
Paul最新的书是《帮助孩子成功，什么有效及原因》。他首次在纽约市的小灰色书系列讲座中阅读了今天故事的一个版本。
Well, today's program was originally produced by Diane Cook and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Wendy Dorr, Jane Marie, Sarah Koenig, and Lisa Pollak. Our senior producer for this show was Julie Snyder. Production help from Todd Bachmann, Laura Bellows, Kevin Clark, Sativa January, Andy Dixon, and Alvin Melathe. Our technical director is Matt Tierney.
好的，今天的节目最初由Diane Cook和我本人制作，Alex Blumberg, Wendy Dorr, Jane Marie, Sarah Koenig, 和 Lisa Pollak参与。我们该节目的资深制片人是Julie Snyder。Todd Bachmann, Laura Bellows, Kevin Clark, Sativa January, Andy Dixon 和 Alvin Melathe提供了制作帮助。我们的技术总监是Matt Tierney。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交易所分发。
Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia, who explains his theory on how to run a radio station this way.
像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人Torey Malatia先生，他以这种方式解释了他经营电台的理论。
But I would just turn everything on and turn knobs and hear all kinds of whoa-oh-whoa-oh sounds, you know?
我就把所有东西都打开，转动旋钮，听各种“呜——”的声音，你知道吗？
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是Ira Glass。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回归。